wie bitte ein kristall nur aus
elektronen unter fachleuten gilt das als
der heilige gral der festkörperphysik
von fast 90 jahren wurde dieses phänomen
vorausgesagt und jetzt ist einem
schweizerischen forschungsteam
tatsächlich die direkte bestätigung
gelungen ein wirklich spektakulärer
nachweis aber wie kann das überhaupt
sein mit einem ausgeklügelten trick
gelangen ihnen der nachweis klick zum
science in future gibt es dreimal pro
woche spannendes heinz videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen frau das ist
wirklich spektakulär und zeigt dass wir
nicht nur in der ferne des weltalls
immer wieder unglaubliche entdeckung
machen sondern auch direkt vor unserer
nase im mikrokosmos es ist alles andere
als ein normaler christ alles ist ein
kristall der ausschließlich aus
elektronen besteht den hat nun ein
forschungsteam aus zürich hergestellt
und hat damit tatsächlich den heiligen
gral der festkörperphysik dingfest
gemacht die existenz eines solchen
kristalls wurde schon von 90 jahren
vorhergesagt doch erst jetzt gelingt
also der direkte nachweis wie kann man
sich einen solchen speziellen kristall
vorstellen und wie gelang den
wissenschaftler sondern wissenschaftlern
der nachweis der bislang technisch als
um machbar galt die spannenden antworten
auf all diese fragen gibt es jetzt hier
bei pixum science and future die rede
ist von sogenannten wiener kristallen
diese bezeichnung geht zurück auf den
ungarischen physiker gene wilder der im
jahre 1934 eine spannende theorie
aufgestellt hatte er gilt als einer der
mitbegründer der theorie der symmetrien
in der quantenmechanik seine vermutung
unter bestimmten voraussetzungen ist es
möglich dass sich die elektronen eines
materials aufgrund ihrer gegenseitigen
elektrische abstoßung in regelmäßigen
christa lförmigen mustern anordnen
können wichtig hierbei die elektrische
abstoßung energie zwischen den
elektronen die dabei größer sein müsste
als ihre bewegungsenergie denn dann so
die überlegung von gene wilder könnten
sich die elektronen so anordnen dass
ihre gesamte energie so gering wie
möglich es ist chemische gesehen
positionieren sich die elektronen dabei
so dass sie möglichst weit voneinander
entfernt sind der blick auf normale
kristalle verdeutlicht den unterschied
atome moleküle union als grund einheiten
der kristalle sind zu regelmäßigen
strukturen angeordnet fachleute sprechen
von einem kristallgitter dass
beispielsweise mit elektronenmikroskopen
oder der röntgenkristallographie
gemessen werden dieser regelmäßige und
strukturierte aufbau von kristallen ist
typisch und unterscheidet diese von
anderen materialien wie beispielsweise
glas auch das hat von außen gesehen eine
glatte form doch molekular ist glas
beispielsweise sehr ungleichmäßig
aufgebaut doch in einem kristall sorgen
die bindungskräfte der atome dafür dass
diese sich quasi von alleine zur
geometrischen gittern anordnen die atome
bleiben dabei fest an bestimmten orten
gebunden ganz im gegensatz zu den
elektronen in metallen und halbleiter
das verhalten der elektronen kann mit
dem einer dynamischen flüssigkeit
verglichen werden die die atom rumpf
umströmt der grund dafür ihre hohe
eigenbewegung um einen gegner kristall
auszubilden müssten die elektronen also
aus kristallisieren ihre
bewegungsenergie muster versinken und
ihre gegenseitige abstoßung dafür sorgen
dass er sich zu einem regelmäßigen getan
ort so also die mittlerweile 90 jahre
alte theorie die bis heute lediglich
eine theorie ist denn der direkte
nachweis war physikerinnen und physikern
weltweit bislang einfach nicht gelungen
kein wunder denn damit sich solche
winter kristalle bilden können braucht
es extreme bedingungen notwendig dafür
sind nicht nur aktive temperaturen auch
die anzahl der freien elektronen im
material muss sehr gering sein eine
weitere herausforderung die bewältigt
werden muss in einem winter kristall
liegt der errechnete abstand der
elektronen bei wenigen nanometern genau
genommen sind es etwa 20 nanometer die
errechnet wurden und damit ist der
abstand der elektronen eines wegener
kristalls achtung 30 mal kleiner als die
wellenlänge von sichtbarem licht und
fakt ist unsere bisherigen mikroskope
und andere nachweismethoden sind nicht
in der lage das mit ihrem
auflösungsvermögen darzustellen und so
geht er exotische zustand der wikinger
kristalle in dem die elektronen ein
regelmäßiges gitter bilden mittlerweile
als heiliger gral der fest körper physik
dazu sagt der wissenschafter attac im
amo klo der an der aktuellen studie
beteiligt war was uns für dieses problem
begeistert hat ist seine einfachheit
zusammen mit seinem team ist es ihnen
nun gelungen einen ganz besonderen
kristall herzustellen dieser besteht
fast ausschließlich aus elektroden ganz
im gegensatz zu normalen kristallen wie
ist das forschungsteam dabei vorgegangen
und wie gelangen den
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern dann der nachweis dass
züricher forschungsteam hatte sich für
eine hauchdünne schicht des halbleiter
materials molybdän diesel init
entschieden diese schicht wurde zwischen
zwei lagen von hexagon allem bornit und
einer als elektroden dienenden
außenschicht von graphen eingeschlossen
entstanden war somit quasi ein sandwich
diese konfiguration sorgte dann dafür
dass sich die elektronen deshalb bleibt
das nur in einer ebene bewegen können
durch das anlegen einer spannung waren
die forschenden in der lage die zahl der
freien elektronen zu minimieren zudem
wurde das ganze abgekühlt und zwar
wenige grad über dem absoluten nullpunkt
der bei minus 273 15 grad celsius liegt
den elektronen sollte somit soviel
bewegungsenergie die möglich entzogen
werden unter diesen umständen sollte
zumindest der theorie zufolge ein
wegener kristall entstehen doch gleich
musste die nächste herausforderung
angegangen werden dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam das nächste problem waren
nachzuweisen dass wir tatsächlich
weniger kristalle in unserem apparaten
doch wie sollte das nachgewiesen werden
wo der abstand der elektronen so gering
ist dass nicht mal die besten mikroskope
dazu in der lage sind dieses problem
löste das forschungsteam mit einem trick
sie konzentrierten sich dabei auf die
sogenannte next zitronen in der
halbleiterschicht die fachleute kennen
diese komplexen quasi teilchen namen
sektoren schon länger es handelt sich um
einen bindungs zustand der aus einem
loch und einem elektron besteht das
elektron ist negativ geladen und das
loch entspricht der abwesenheit einer
negativen ladung somit ist es positiv
geladen und beide ziehen sich
gegenseitig an dieser bindungs zustand
kann durch licht angeregt werden genau
diese tatsache machte sich das
forschungsteam zunutze löste durch die
bestrahlung mit licht einer bestimmten
frequenz einen resonanz effekt aus und
dieser wiederum ist mit hilfe der
optischen spektroskopie nachweisbar wenn
die elektronen 60 zu einem kristall
angeordnet sind kommt es zu
wechselwirkungen zwischen den elektronen
und den löchern als ihre nachbarn
dadurch erzeugen die sogenannte next
zitronen eine messbare veränderung ist
wieder abgegebenen lichts es kommt zu
einem effekt den man von autorennen aus
dem fernsehen kennt die räder eines
autos oder eines fahrrads scheinen dabei
ab einer bestimmten sehr schnellen
geschwindigkeit stillzustehen dann macht
es sogar den eindruck dass sie sich in
die umgekehrte richtung drehen der grund
dafür die kamera macht nur alle paar
millisekunden einen schnappschuss der
räder wenn sich in der zwischenzeit das
rad um genau einen speichen abstand
bewegt scheint es so als würde sich das
rad nicht mehr drehen zurück zum binger
kristall hier sind es die wandernden ex
zitronen die still zu stehen scheint
wenn ein wegen der kristalle material
vorhanden ist sie bewegen sich mit einer
ganz bestimmten geschwindigkeit vor die
vom abstand der elektronen im
kristallgitter abhängig ist und die
beobachtung des züricher forschungsteams
sind super spannend denn der theorie
zufolge sollten die elektronen ein
zweidimensionales dreiecks gitter
bleiben dazu schreibt das forschungsteam
eine gruppe theoretischer physiker und
semmler von der harvard university hatte
theoretisch berechnet wie sich dieser
effekt in den beobachteten
lichtfrequenzen der ex zitronen zeigen
sollte und genau das haben wir auch im
labor gesehen heißt also die beobachtung
des forschungsteams stimmten mit den
voraussagen die theoretisch gemacht
wurden über 1 dem forschungsteam aus der
schweiz ist somit ein direkter nachweis
der regelmäßigen anordnung der
elektronen im kristall gelungen ein
wilder kristall konnte direkt beobachtet
und nachgewiesen werden die vor fast 90
jahren gemachten aussagen von jean
winder können damit bestätigt werden der
heilige gral der physik aufgespült dazu
das fazit des forschungsteams unserer
ergebnisse eröffnen neue möglichkeiten
soll stark korrelierten elektronen zu
untersuchen und damit in bisher
unerforschte gebiete vorzudringen neues
teilchen gefunden oder und ermöglicht
neue erkenntnisse in der teilchenphysik
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren das
macht schlau und ist kostenlos und das
geht übrigens auch hier oder mit dem
button unter jedem video bis dann bleibt
dran